if I just want to like dip my toe in the
hole like Marie Kondo thing like could I
do it like what what do you do it take
six months okay well you don't have to
go full condo let's ease you in I am an
extremist Beth are you I got a half
answer then you might want to start I
was going to suggest you start with the
bathrooms because those drawers are
usually easier to be like junk junk so
much junk in than a couple stuff that's
all that so did I but I said thank you
for sending me these a note will go to
my sister yeah yeah she can condo her
house fast ball I'm gonna do that but do
and because I think Marie has her set
way of doing it but I think if you start
small an easier way and you'll be you'll
be addicted it kind of gets addicting
okay so here's what we'll do I can't do
this alone people I want help so if
you're watching and you have a messy
bathroom let's commit to doing this
together okay take a before photo of
your bathroom this week posted I hate
that I'm forcing I'm asking y'all so I'm
gonna have to do this it's gonna change
your life to Instagram with at V Kelly
Clarkson show and hashtag Kelly condo
before you know and I'll do it too you
have to now you gotta miss a world show
and I said Kelly condo after get over
doing there I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this